pas
tél
ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
cet après midi les sénateurs poursuivent
l'examen du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture
ils ont entamé le titre iii qui consiste
à inscrire l'agriculture dans une
politique de développement durable des
territoires
parmi elles les thèmes abordés la
préservation du foncier agricole tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle très
bonne science à tous nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 411 tendance a inséré un article
additionnel après l'article 12 ha alors
je vais appeler l'amendement 411 qui le
défend blâmer review merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur rapporteur chers
collègues
encore une fois vous comprendrez bien
sûr que c'est un amendement que je
pourrai a qualifié d' appel puisque
c'est anna non dissimulée entre
rapporteur c'est encore une fois un
rapport mais mon collègue tout à l'heure
jean pierre sueur le disait c'était la
seule manière que nous avions deux
d'entamer ce débat puisque les articles
que nous les amendements que nous avions
déposé en accord avec les jeunes qui
travaillent pour la faim en faveur de
l'installation n'ont pas passé le crible
de l'article 40 donc nous nous replions
derrière cet amendement d'appel
il s'agit dans cet amendement d'une
demande de rapports bien entendu sur les
installations n'ont aidé on a eu le
débat déjà tout à l'heure je reviens pas
sur ce que nous avons dit sur la demie
et s'est mis mais ça serait justement
particulièrement intéressant de voir si
c'est la surface ou si si le projet qui
fait la validité de
la pérennité de l'exploitation le
renouvellement des générations est un
enjeu crucial pour l'avenir la culture
la validité de nos territoires et
aujourd'hui malheureusement ces
installations ne sont plus suffisantes
pour compenser les départs à la retraite
et les cessations d'activité il est
regrettable de constater que les deux
tiers des installations agricoles sont
des installations n'ont aidé encore dans
beaucoup de départements de région c'est
à dire sans le versement de la dotation
cette situation nous paraît parfois
normal devriez en compagne et la plupart
des candidats à l'installation
et nous souhaitons donc comprendre
pourquoi la majorité des candidats à
l'installation est écarté du dispositif
national et surtout une fois qu'ils sont
installés malgré tout qu'est ce qu'il
devienne leur exploitation se dire si
réellement c'était une exploitation qui
ne méritait pas de regarder parce
qu'elle était vouée à l'échec économique
ou au contraire s'il malgré le fait
qu'il ne soit pas aidé et bien et
continue elle perdure et elle trouve sa
place dans le monde de l'agriculture
donc nous estimons que cette analyse
devrait vraisemblablement conduire un
allègement du dispositif des aides à
l'installation et des différents
critères d'éligibilité
merci quel est l'avis du rapporteur
merci monsieur le président nous avons
eu l'occasion à travers le l'amendement
qui ont été posées monsieur sur
d'aborder ce point j'ai proposé que nous
puissions au sein du parlement au sein
du sénat en particulier créé un groupe
de travail avec le syndicalisme jeunes
pour aborder ce point
donc je vais mandat aux interviews
qu'elle était d'accord de retirer le
seul amendement puisque lcl le dis
chaque fois que je ne suis pas favorable
au rapport monsieur le ministre votre
avis même avis que le rapporteur
monsieur le président mais des
propositions de retrait avec que les
explications suivantes le phénomène des
installations aidées est
particulièrement bien renseignés par le
ministère de l'agriculture
nous avons dix mille installations n'ont
aidé annuel sur ces dix mille 20 %
correspond à des transferts entre époux
ce qui justifie qu'il n'est pas d'être
particulière 40% sont le fait de
personnes ils sont âgés de plus de 40
ans ce qui explique que ne puisse pas
être éligibles aux aides à
l'installation ça rejoint le débat
tout à l'heure et enfin sur les 40 %
restants qui ont moins de 40 ans un peu
moins de la moitié ne dispose pas de la
capacité professionnelle requise et on
rejoint là aussi le débat sur
l'acquisition des capacités
professionnelles et sur les diplômes
nécessaires à l'installation
donc pour toutes ces raisons je crois
qu'elle a froid nous avons une situation
qui est bien renseigné par le mr à la
culture et en même temps une explication
à l'absence d' aide sur ses
installations dans l'année des c'est
vers viau le maintenez vous vous le
retirez vous le retirez je vous remercie
monsieur muller j'appelle l'amendement
629 rectifier si vous voulez bien le
défendre
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues cet amendement porte sur la
question épineuse des prix des terres
agricoles qui peuvent constituer un
obstacle à l'installation
alors il existe un arrêté du ministre de
l'agriculture en date du 20 novembre
2008 est paru le 5 février 2009 aux jo
qui précise la valeur des terres
décidée dans l'attenté de la publication
du répertoire de la valeur des terres
agricoles s'est arrêté définit la valeur
vénale pour les deux catégories de
référence les terres labourables et les
prairies naturelles
il décline par département et par région
naturelle des prix dominante
les maximales et minimales et il sert de
référence dans le cadre du dispositif de
révision de prix s'affairent sur cette
question il nous paraît plus juste de
fixer la valeur vénale
en considérant lusage du sol et donc son
rendement économique
ainsi nous estimons que les éléments de
fixation de la valeur vénale doivent
être révisés afin d'intégrer comme
indicateur de base
le nombre moyen d'années de carrière
dans l'agriculteur y la valeur du
fermage
selon les barèmes départementaux qui
existe dans les arrêtés préfectoraux
ma proposition est donc la suivante la
valeur d'une terre agricole serait
estimée en faisant le produit du nombre
moyen d'années de carrière du
ils ont fois la valeur locative le
statut du fermage serment de barèmes
ainsi prenons par exemple un fermage à
100 euros de l'hectare par an sur 30 ans
ramène la terre un usage de 3000 euros
l'hectare de valeur vénale
nous estimons que cette proposition est
doublement intéressante premièrement
elle répond en partie à la question de
l'installation
quand un jeune s'installe le prix du
foncier est lourd
c'est un investissement qui peut le
diminuer qui peut le contraindre dans
ses investissements en capital
d'exploitation et nous paraît donc
intéressant d'encadrer le prix des
terres agricoles et de prendre des
critères objectifs
en l'occurrence la valeur économique des
terres et puis un deuxième raison et je
terminerai par là tout à l'heure mon
amendement visant à reconnaître le
statut d'exploitant à partir des heures
travaillées plutôt que la surface a été
rejetée alors puisque la surface reste
le critère de référence
si on veut faciliter l'installation et
bien faisons en sorte que les prix de la
terre ne dérive pas et c'est donc le
sens de cet amendement le merci monsieur
laporte ravi s'il vous plaît oui merci
monsieur président l'article l 312 3 du
code rural prévoit la tenue d'un chaque
département de répertoire permettant
d'évaluer la valeur des terres agricoles
trois notions sont analysés la valeur
vénale la valeur locative et la valeur
de rendement
la valeur de rendement des terres
agricoles est calculée par régions
naturelles en fonction notamment du
revenu d'exploitation
cet amendement propose de remplacer le
revenu soit à sion par la valeur des
fermages or la valeur des fermages
permet de calculer la valeur locative et
n'a rien à voir et que rendement donc
cet amendement risque de semer la
confusion
j'y suis défavorable monsieur le
ministre votre avis défavorable
également monsieur président et ne
souhaitons pas non plus
faire de lien entre la valeur des terres
et des usages qui est en effet parce que
je crois que les deux choses sont
distinctes bien le maintenez vous
monsieur muller vous le maintenez donc
je mets ou madame pour explications de
vote les minimes et chers collègues nous
nous avons plusieurs fois abordé ce
thème de la sacralisation des terres
agricoles on l'a fait dans le grenelle
on l'a aussi fait dans la halle dans la
loi de finances sur portant budget de
votre ministère monsieur le ministre et
on nous a dit que nous reviendrions sur
ce sujet dans la lma est ce que nous
sommes en bon endroit pour discuter de
la valeur des terres agricoles puisque
le problème de l'installation est
évidemment liée à à la question de la
valorisation de la terre lorsque vous
avez des expropriations de jeunes
agriculteurs ou des expropriations pour
des projets industriels à venir dont
personne n'est sûr qu'ils viendront
qu'ils verront un jour le jour
précisément cette sacralisation des
terres agricoles est quand même un sujet
que nous devions aborder dans ce texte
je suis pas très sûr que nous ne soyons
pas au bon endroit pour le faire
est-ce que vous souhaitez répondre à
madame boulet bien alors je mets aux
voix cet amendement qu'un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
ministre qui est pour et qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté maintenant nous
avons trois amendements qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion que 1614 de
notre collègue muller le 549 du
président collard et le 165 rectifié de
madame hervio jeu muller vous avez la
parole
monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ce le rapporteur
chers collègues
cet amendement porte sur l'amélioration
de l'information
quant à la disponibilité en terre
l'article l 331 2 est relatif à
l'obligation pour l'exploitant de faire
connaître à l'autorité administrative
son intention de cesser son activité
dix-huit mois au minimum avant la prise
d'effet de la retraite
il s'agit ici de la déclaration
d'intention de cesser son activité
la dei c2a qui indique les
caractéristiques de l'exploitation
libérables et son devenir
sept des lycées de zap notamment être
utilisé pour être portés à la
connaissance d'éventuels candidats dans
les répertoires départ installation
toutes les organisations agricoles
admettre qu'un projet d'installation est
long à mettre en oeuvre le délai actuel
de 18 mois
retenez dans la loi est trop tenues trop
ténus car le repérage du ou des
repreneurs
les discussions et arbitrages à mettre
en oeuvre je pense notamment aux
échanges avec les propriétaires le
parcours d'installation je pense aux
formations éventuelle à mettre en oeuvre
tout cela nécessite une période beaucoup
plus longue
le fait de faire connaître au public
cette disponibilité en terre est
impérative pour se donner les moyens de
toucher le plus grand nombre de
candidats possibles surtout au vu des
difficultés qu'il y à s'installer
aujourd'hui monsieur le président que
l'un votre amendement s'il vous plaît
pj monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
renouvellement des générations est un
enjeu majeur un jeu crucial même pour
l'avenir de l'agriculture et la vitalité
de nos territoires
n'oublions jamais qu'il s'agit là d'une
des rares activités non délocalisables
qui ennuie des emplois dans beaucoup
d'autres secteurs matériel agricole
transports commerces artisanat industrie
agroalimentaire distribution services
etc
l'agriculture à l'évidence est donc un
prêt requis à des territoires vivent à
des territoires dynamiques
or on le sait tous les installations ne
sont pas suffisantes pour compenser les
départs à la retraite et les cessations
d'activité quel jeune en effet peut-il
avoir envie d'un labeur de tous les
jours pour rappel rémy avec en plus une
cotisation minimale à payer pour
bénéficier de l'assurance maladie et la
perspective d'une retraite qui n'atteint
même pas le minimum vieillesse servi aux
autres on pourrait s'étonner d'ailleurs
comme projet de loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture ne contiennent aucune
disposition sur ce sujet la commission
de l'économie introduit et je le
félicite et remercie de nouveaux
articles l'un qui encourage
l'installation sous forme sociétaire et
l'autre qui formalise une procédure
d'enregistrement de tout projet
d'installation
c'est un progrès certes qu'il faut
souligner mais qui reste un peu faible
et il faut faire émerger de nouvelles
candidatures à l'installation est aussi
favoriser la mise en relation entre
cédants et repreneurs et dans cet
objectif notre amendement propose de
porter le délai dont dispose les
exploitants pour faire connaître à
l'autorité administrative leur intention
de cesser l'exploitation et indiquer si
elle va devenir disponibles de 18 mois à
24 mois au moins avant leur départ à la
retraite il nous paraît en effet que la
recherche d'un repreneur mais aussi la
mise en oeuvre d'un projet
d'installation nécessite de notre point
de vue une période plus longue
d'autre part afin de susciter nous
malgré la tuerie est impératif que ces
informations soient portés à la
connaissance du public or l'article
332 n'en fait pas une obligation mais
une faculté ce que l'on peut regretter
voilà pour toutes ces raisons mes chers
collègues je vous demande de d'apporter
votre soutien à cette excellente
amendements oh merci monsieur connaît
maintenant je vais appeler le 165 répit
et madame hervio s'il veut bien le
défendre
merci monsieur le président monsieur
président moody's chers collègues chaque
exploitant agricole qui part en retraite
doit en informer l'autorité
administrative et lui transmettre les
caractéristiques de son exploitation
ainsi que la mise en disponibilité ou
non de cette dernière
le futur retraité peut alors décider de
rendre ces informations publiques mais
on remarque encore que trop souvent il
ne le fait pas votre amendement vise
tout simplement à rendre systématique la
diffusion la publicité de ces
informations ont laissé on l'a répété
les fermetures d'exploitation se
multiplient au point qu'aujourd'hui un
exploitant agricole sur six envisage de
mettre la clé sous la porte dans l'année
à venir
pourtant nous savons tous que pour
chaque exploitation agricole qui ferment
ce sont non seulement des emplois mais
les savoir-faire qui sont perdus et en
réalité c'est d'une part essentielle de
la vie de notre territoire qui risque de
disparaître
nous l'avons souvent répété il ya
urgence à favoriser l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs
urgence à organiser les rencontres des
anciens et des nouveaux à rétablir la
chaîne de transmission entre les
générations
or de toute évidence il est impossible
que des explications soient reprises
dans des bonnes conditions si je peux me
permettre de le dire
si personne ne sait quel est disponible
deux mois on ne peut pas anticiper
il n'y a pas de passage de relais sans
communication il est aussi absolument
primordial de favoriser l'installation
et non l'agrandissement des
exploitations existantes
or souvent les voisins du cédant ce sont
les premiers informés de la vente de
l'exploitation donc favorise
l'agrandissement mes chers collègues il
nous semble que cette proposition est
simplement de bon sens et qu'en ces
temps de rigueur budgétaire
elle a surtout l'immense avantage de ne
pas coûter 1 euros à la collectivité
donc j'appelle
tout à fait votre clémence pour adopter
cet amendement merci madame herviou
monsieur le rapporteur 18 24 ou 36 donc
sur le monument à 614 les nous savons
qu'aujourd'hui les espaces agricoles
doivent signaler mais ça l'orientation
de partis à la retraite 18 mois avant et
donc allonger ce délai de prévenance à
trois ans mais en paraît tout à fait
excessive
par ailleurs il convient que l'intention
de partir la retraite ne soient
communiqués qu'aux personnes il ya un
projet d'installation et non compris
dans sa population
j'ajoute que le téléphone fonctionne
très bien en campagne les le bouche à
oreille va encore mieux et je pense que
18 mois c'est déjà un délai très
suffisant et qui me paraît inutile d'y
toucher sur l'amendement du président
colin c'est la même observation
lui au contraire oui c'est 24 mois sur
24 mois d'août ces trois ans qui dit
mieux
défavorable ce prix en colère en ce qui
concerne l'amendement de de madame
herviou 165 le président nous pensons
qu'il est trop lourd inutile d'obliger
les champs mais culture communiquer au
public
l'intégralité des cessations
d'exploitations écoles c'est donc un
avis défavorable sur les trois
amendements bien nous allons entendre
l'avis du ministre sur les 3 le ministre
le même avis que le rapporteur monsieur
le président je pense qu'il faut pas
alourdir exagérément les procédures je
pense également que 18 mois c'est une
durée suffisante par ailleurs pour
l'exploitant lui-même qui connaît pas
ses droits de liquidation à la retraite
lui demander deux ans à l'avance dalle
en cessation d'activité c'est plus
compliqué qu autre chose
est-ce qu'ils sont maintenus monsieur
muller j'appelle dans l'ordre est
maintenu explications de vote le plus
brièvement campouriez s'il vous plaît
merci
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues vos réponses en fait n'ont pas
convaincu pour trois raisons la première
c'est qu'il s'agit bien d'améliorer la
formation et que en la matière j'estime
que la transparence repose enfin
pourrait reposer sur autre chose que le
bouche à oreille dont vous avez parlé
l'information de l'ensemble des
repreneurs potentiels me paraît une une
bonne condition la deuxième c'est le
rapporteur disait qu'il n'était à titre
personnel pas pas très favorable moi je
constate que toutes les organisations
professionnelles agricoles admettent que
un projet d'installation c'est très long
à mettre en oeuvre et aller au delà des
18 mois c'est tout simplement je croit
tenir compte de la réalité du terrain
puis la troisième raison c'est que
l'installation est une chose trop
importante et on la matière plus de
transformer plus de transparence s'est
amélioré la possibilité de
l'installation encore vous aurez compris
que l'amendement est maintenant
président colin vous le retirez vous le
maintenez et madame hervé aux anémones
vous le maintenez aussi bon alors
j'appelle 614 ce que monsieur muller
ceux qui sont pour veulent bien approuvé
relevé lendemain avis contraire il n'est
pas adopté le 6 549 rectifiait du
président colin ceux qui sont pauvres
veulent bien levé la main habib
contraire il n'est pas adopté et
maintenant madame hervio explications de
vote
c'est ce que j'avais cru deviner
policiers le président je crois que
c'est un problème donc on a évoqué qui
est non seulement typiquement français
mais je crois que dans son ensemble
l'union européenne est touché par cette
difficulté du renouvellement des
générations d'agriculteurs puisqu'on
note seulement 7% des régulateurs
européens qui ont moins de 35 ans donc
je crois que quelles que soient les
propositions que l'on puisse faire pour
aller dans le sens d'une meilleure
information favorisant la transmission
eh bien il faudrait que nous puissions y
aller il faut agir pour accompagner au
mieux les différentes installations et
nous aurions avec le parlement
p1 tout intérêt à nous pencher sur ce
problème je rappelle qu'en 2008 il ya eu
un rapport d'initiative au parlement
européen dans ce sens qui disait que la
pac devrait à l'avenir avoir pour
objectif de supprimer les obstacles
auxquels se heurtent actuellement les
jeunes pour accéder l'activité agricole
il prend des ils prenaient acte pardon
de la nécessité d'améliorer l'efficacité
des politiques des de l'installation et
il recommandait d'introduire plus de
souplesse dans les procédures
d'installation dans les procédures de
transmission des exploitations par tous
les moyens possible installation
progressive prise en compte de la
validation des acquis antérieurs du
candidat lorsqu'il n'avait pas le niveau
suffisant et dérogation à la condition
d'âge quand le candidat présenté un
projet d'installation viable notamment
dans les zones les plus défavorisées
donc je crois que nous serions dans tous
les
les amendements que nous venons de voir
dans la droite ligne des recommandations
également du parlement européen et
j'espère que nous pourrions avoir
je vous remercie
alors je mets ou voix l'amendement de
madame hervio qui pour avis contraire il
n'est pas adoptée à l'article 12 bis je
n'ai pas d'amendement je le mets au voir
s'ils voulaient bien adopté l'article 12
bis 12b truck n ya pas d'amendement pas
d'avis contraire il est adopté
après l'article 12 b nous avons six
amendements qui vont faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune j'appelle tout
d'abord le 292 activié monsieur leucan
c'est le président anselmi chers
collègues comme vous le savez l'unité de
référence de l'article l 331 2 du code
rural constitue la valeur étalon utilisé
par le contrôle des structures l'article
l 312 5 précise que le préfet du
département pourront établir la valeur
ha utilise la moyenne des installations
au cours des cinq dernières années
cette moyenne est calculée sur la base
d'un rapport annuel établi par
l'autorité administrative et qui rendu
public
or il s'avère d'une part que dans de
nombreux départements ce rapport n'est
pas porté à la connaissance de tous et
des doutes existent même sur la
rédaction effective de ce document en
outre aucune précision n'est apportée
sur la notion d'installation
à l'exception des conditions de capacité
ou d'expérience professionnelle ainsi la
pratique démontre que ce ne sont
recensés dans ce document est donc dans
le calcul de la moyenne des
installations que les installations
dites aider en conséquence cette moyenne
est loin d'être représentative des
installations dans le département
d'autant plus que des études récentes
ont pu démontrer que la part des
installations non aidées par l'état
pouvait représenter jusqu'à 40 % des
installations total dans une région
il convient donc un minima de modifier
le seuil du l331 deux petites 1 en lui
donnant une seule valeur et non pas
d'ouvrir à la discrétion des
départements la possibilité de jouer sur
une tranche comprise entre une et deux
unités de référence dans le texte de
plus il est paradoxal en fonction de ce
qui a été dit précédemment que le seuil
municipal minimale par temps de passage
en contrôle des structures soit établir
unité de référence puisque cela signifie
concrètement qu'un nombre conséquent
d'installations aidées est exclu du
contrôle
on peut théoriquement affirmé que la
moitié des installations aidées sont en
dessous de cette moyenne d'une unité de
référence et que l'autre est au dessus
pour toutes ces raisons il proposé de
retenir un seul et unique et national de
0,5 unité de référence beaucoup plus à
même à apporter au contrôle des
structures les moyens de remplir sa
mission
il n'en demeurera pas moins que les
unités de référence reste trop variable
selon les départements
reflétant ainsi la diversité des
structures d'exploitation dans les
départements et régions naturelles
merci monsieur le président que l'un si
vous voulez défendre le vôtre une seule
résidence michaud collègues un
amendement qui est identique à celui qui
viennent d'être présentés détritus par
nos collègues du groupe crc qui
ressemble d'ailleurs aussi à s'y
méprendre aux 166 sous-amendement 166 et
615 vise à étendre le champ
d'application du contrôle des structures
aujourd'hui sont en effet soumises à
autorisation préalable
les extractions agrandissons en réunion
d'exploitations agricoles lorsque la
surface totale mise en valeur excède le
seuil fixé par le schéma directeur
départemental des structures
ce seuil est compris entre une houle
australe unité de référence définie à
l'article l 312 5
il est proposé de fixer un seuil unique
et national de 0,5 fois l'unité de
référence bout comme usa même nous
semble-t-il d'apporter au contrôle des
structures les moyens de remplir sa
mission et ainsi de favoriser
l'installation
merci le 615 monsieur muller voulait
bien le défendre
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre c'est le rapporteur chers
collègues
l'amendement était en grande partie
défendu par mon collègue le cam
je voudrais simplement rajouté que la
question du contrôle des structures est
une question importante
on peut considérer aujourd'hui que ce
contrôle des structures ne fonctionnent
pas de manière optimale c'est un
euphémisme en témoigne la concentration
des terres la concentration des
exploitations agricoles et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle la modification du
seuil de référence me paraît tout à fait
essentiel merci j'appelle le 166
rectifié monsieur botrel
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le contrôle
des structures est un outil de mise en
application de la politique
d'orientation agricole de l'état qui
permet de contrôler les transferts de
propriétés ayant pour conséquence de
modifier l'exploitation du fonds
agricole
historiquement il s'agissait d'empêcher
des grande concentration des terres
agricoles afin de promouvoir plutôt un
modèle d'agriculture familiale et
l'installation de jeunes agriculteurs
plutôt que l'agrandissement n'est loi du
23 février 2005 et du 5 janvier 2006 ont
nettement assoupli le contrôle public du
fait d' exploitation alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous constatons la
nécessité d'une intervention visant à
prolonger à protéger le foncier agricole
et à assurer le renouvellement des
générations d'agriculteurs nos
amendements visent donc à rétablir des
mesures de contrôle des structures
agricoles plus forte et plus efficace
les installations les agrandissements ou
les réunions d'exploitations agricoles
sont soumises
à autorisation préalable mais sous
réserve de leur portée et notamment de
la surface concernée qui doit excéder le
seuil fixé par le schéma directeur
départemental des structures or ce seuil
cela a été dit est compris entre une et
deux fois l'unité de référence définie à
l'article l 312 5 qui correspond à la
surface qui permet d'assurer la
viabilité d'exploitation compte tenu de
la nature des cultures et des ateliers
de production hors sol ainsi que d
autres activités agricoles notre
amendement propose que ce soit ils
soient fixées à la moitié de l'unité de
référence afin que les contrôles soient
efficaces et permet de réellement de
favoriser les installations
d'agriculteurs et non les
agrandissements
nous estimons d'ailleurs qu'à terme la
concentration des collations agricole va
contribuer à dévitaliser le monde rural
que l'agrandissement d'exploration nous
conduit à enclencher un cercle vicieux
excluant les nouveaux entrants sur le
long terme notamment ceux qui ne sont
pas issus du secteur agricole
car ces exploitations importante
trouveront difficilement des repreneurs
une fois remise sur le marché elles
seront beaucoup trop cher
je vous remercie ses 116 monsieur muller
voulez vous le présenter monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues
sept amendements portent sur l'action
des safer dans le contrôle des
structures actuellement les opérations
relatives à la mise en valeur d'un bien
reçu de la safer sont exonérés d'une
demande d'une autorisation préalable
d'exploiter si elles se traduisent par
le démantèlement d'une exploitation ou
si elle contribue en constituer une en
dessous d'un seuil de tarifs fixés au
niveau départemental le texte prévoit
que pour toutes ses opérations exonéré
d'autorisation préalable le régime de
simples des plats déclaration s'applique
l'intervention de la safer dans une
opération ne justifie pas que ladite
opération des rouges au régime
d'autorisation dans la mesure où le
contrôle des structures à vocation à
s'appliquer
l'article l 331 1
dispose en effet que je cite le contrôle
des structures des exploitations
agricoles s'applique à la mise en valeur
des terres agricoles ou des ateliers de
production hors sol au sein d'une
exploitation agricole
je souligne quelle que soit la forme ou
le mode d'organisation juridique de
celle ci et quel que soit le titre en
vertu duquel la mise en valeur est
assurée un régime dérogatoire a été
accordé par la loi d'orientation du 5
janvier 2006 pour la mise en valeur de
biens d'origine familiale pour les
opérations donation location vente ou
succession qui s'inscrivent dans un
cadre familial jusqu'au troisième degré
l'opération s'inscrit alors dans le
régime de simple déclaration préalable
évitant ainsi la mise en concurrence
avec un ou des candidats éventuellement
plus prioritaires dans le cadre du
schéma directeur départemental des
structures merci non non c'est pas fini
on va écouter et je regrette le temps
est passé
non on est à 27 secondes de plus il faut
vraiment faire un effort chers amis dont
je m'excuse mais je dois tenir pour tout
le monde
monsieur merceron pour le 460 l'an 5
secondes ça va 10 secondes mais trente
secondes c'est trop merceron donne à
penser le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues le régime de
déclaration simples applicables aux
biens familiaux est subordonnée à la
condition que les biens soient libres de
location a contrario lorsque ces biens
sont loués ils font l'objet d'une simple
demande d'autorisation d'exploiter dans
ce cas la cdoa donne son avis sur les
projets en concurrence celui du fermi en
place et celui du propriétaire qui
exerce son droit de reprise
or ces principes sont battus en brèche
quand bien même les surfaces reprise
sont noués elles peuvent faire l'objet
d'une déclaration simple par le
repreneur dans le mois qui suit le
départ du fermier depuis 2006 beaucoup
de fermiers sont ainsi émincé de leur
entreprise
en conséquence il est nécessaire de
supprimer les mots au jour de leurs
déclarations afin que le régime de
déclaration ne s'applique qu'aux seuls
bien effectivement libre en location
merci monsieur le rapporteur va
travailler sur les six amendements
allaient votre autorisation monsieur le
président je donnerai une même avis pour
292 557 615 et 66 en effet l'article 331
2 du code rural soumis à autorisation
mitre hâtives les installations
agrandissement et réunion d'exploitation
écoles lorsque la surface totale
dépassant ceux compris entre une et deux
fois est une telle référence fixé au
niveau de chaque département
le président ne m'en propose donc
d'appliquer le contrôle structure d un
seuil légal à la moitié des nuitées de
référence ce qui correspond à un
investissement important de son champ
d'application
une telle disposition risque rire et me
semble-t-il de charger inutilement les
cdo à les petites opérations étant déjà
presque toujours autorisés je ne crois
pas souhaitable remettre en cause les
crédits matin en 2006 le contrôle des
structures
voilà la vie qui donne qui est donnée
pour 292 16 57 6 ans qu'elle 66 reste
monsieur le président le le muller 16 et
le 460 et bien évidemment les affaires
n'échappe pas au contrôle des structures
celui ci est toutefois adoucie par
exemple lorsque l'attribution d'un bien
présenté par lesaffaires a pour objet
l'agrandissement d'une exploitation ce
qui est souvent le cas
l'autorisation nécessaire que si la
superficie totale résultante est
supérieur à deux fois
unité de référence par ailleurs
certaines opérations d affaires sont
soumises un simple régime de déclaration
et non d'autorisation les safer nommé
ziff vague que d'une négation très
limitées contre la structure qui est une
soupe quitter un monde ancien et ne
semble pas causer de dysfonctionnements
particulier c'est donc un avis
défavorable et en ce qui concerne
l'amendement présenté par notre collègue
jean claude merceron l'article l 331 2
du code rural soumis la mise en valeur
des biens agricoles familiaux un régime
de s'impliquent la ration et non
d'autorisation préalable
il précise toutefois que ses biens doit
être libre de location au jour de la
déclaration
cet amendement prévoit que ses biens
doit être
libre de location en supprimant la
condition selon laquelle cette absence
de location s'applique au moment de la
déclaration et au port on est pourtant
utile précisé par sécurité juridique à
quel moment ce après si cette condition
est pour avoir l'expertisé juridique je
souhaiterais monsieur le ministre
d'avoir votre avis bien et bien
d'enlever du ministre tout de suite sur
ces six amendements sur cinq premiers
amendements monsieur le président le 292
rectifier le 557 rectifier le 615 actifs
y ait le sens 36 rectifier et le silence
s est un avis défavorable
je précise là aussi que au delà des
aspects techniques et une question de
philosophie politique sur le texte tout
ce qui peut alourdir exagérément le
contrôle des structures ne nous paraît
pas favorable et ne nous paraît pas
conforme aussi à une agriculture moderne
qui a besoin de passer un cap
cette loi est là pour faire passer un
cap à l'agriculture française
elle n'est pas là pour renforcer les
contrôles exagérément je précise par
ailleurs que je suis un peu surpris que
des parlementaires qui ont posé des
amendements de simplification sur les
contrôles qui pèsent sur les structures
pose ensuite d'autres amendements
qu'elle en dise considérablement de
contrôle des structures
tout ça n'est pas très cohérent en fin
d'année un argument la loi de 2006 a
déjà modifié le contrôle des structures
rappellent que les baux sont de 9 ans
c'est à dire qu'avant même qu'un bail se
soit écoulée vous demander à nouveau une
modification du contrôle des structures
tout ça ne me paraît vraiment pas
raisonnable
donc avis défavorable en revanche à vis
de sagesse sur le code 62 monsieur
dubois bien alors monsieur le cam
votre amendement est il maintenu il est
maintenu je le mets aux voix ceux qui
sont favorables à l'option veulent bien
levé la main avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté le chocolat un vote amendement
est il maintenu non il est retiré je
vous remercie monsieur muller votre
amendement était le maintenue bien je le
mets au voir ce qu'ils sont pas en
option veulent bien levé la main avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté le 166 me
battrai pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le président la suite de
l'intervention et de la réponse de
monsieur le ministre je voudrais quand
même je voudrais dire rappeler qu'il ya
quand même un problème si quatre groupes
politiques notre assemblée ont souhaité
réagir sur le même sujet ce qui veut
dire qu'on constate malgré tout une
situation qui n'est pas normale dans nos
départements
et si on a parlé d'alourdissement des
procédures on me donnait un exemple du
fonctionnement de la cdoa de mon
département des côtes d'armor cdo qui
travaillait six heures il y a quelques
années et aujourd'hui en une heure et
demie le contrôle des structures et
effectuer une fois par mois donc on a
considérablement alléger les procédures
et on pourrait retrouver sûrement on a
une petite marge de manoeuvre de ce côté
là moi je n'hésite pas à dire que par
rapport aux exemples qu'on m'a fourni et
je connais un peu le fonctionnement des
structures enfin je les ai connus dans
le passé en tous les cas on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui et sont largement devenu
monsieur le ministre des passoires
alors je crois qu'il faudrait revenir
aux fondamentaux et vous nous avez parlé
à plusieurs occasions de la nécessité de
rétablir la régulation dans le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
agricoles
là il y à véritablement quelque chose à
faire merci donc je le mets aux voileux
166 rectifié ceux qui sont pauvres
veulent bien levé la main avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté et j'appelle
maintenant le 616 monsieur muller
explications de vote vous avez la parole
ce président monsieur le ministre ce le
rapporteur chers collègues le coeur de
cet amendement porte sur le régime
dérogatoire accordé par la loi
d'orientation du 5 janvier 2006 pour la
mise en valeur des biens d'origine
familiale pour les opérations dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure donation location
vente ou succession qui s'inscrit dans
un cadre familial jusqu'au troisième
degré l'opération s'inscrit alors dans
le régime de simple déclaration
préalable évitant ainsi la mise en
concurrence avec un ou des candidats
éventuellement plus prioritaires dans le
cadre du schéma directeur départemental
des structures pour nous ce régime n'est
pas justifié et s'apparente un passe
droit
bien entendu il est légitime que le
caractère familial d'une opération de ce
type puisse être privilégiée d'ailleurs
cette priorité est prévue est appliquée
dans le cadre du statut du fermage à
l'article l 411 58 qui est relatif au
droit de reprise du bailleur
propriétaire pour son conjoint
partenaire pacsé ou descendants majeur
en effet dans la mesure où le candidat
familiale est situé au même rang de
priorité que d'autres éventuels
candidats
il bénéficiera de l'autorisation et
deviendra prioritaire de fait puisqu'il
bénéficiera de la faveur familiale pour
la signature d'un bail rural
en conclusion cet amendement ne limite
pas la priorité donnée aux repreneurs
familiale s'il est situé au même niveau
que d'autres repreneurs
par contre il permet d'améliorer le
contrôle des structures
je voudrais quand même revenir ici sur
deux observations qui ont été faites la
première du rapporteur tout de même le
contrôle des structures est loin de
fonctionner correctement
la concentration des structures
d'exploitation continue elle a commencé
il ya bien longtemps et le mouvement
n'est toujours pas stoppé par rapport à
la réponse monsieur le ministre je reste
un petit peu surpris tout de même nous
disons nous sommes dans une loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et vous
nous dites qu'il faut passer le cap et
vous laissez entendre que le contrôle
des structures ne doit pas freiner la
concentration des exploitations
moi je trouve au contraire qu'une loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture
eh bien elle prend en compte les
nouvelles formes d'exploitations
agricoles
on a parlé déjà ce matin des personnes
qui s'installent sur de petites surfaces
qui font vivre une famille tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont
agriculteurs qu'ils transforment leurs
produits qui les valorisent sur des
circuits courts
je veux donner un exemple je connais des
gens céréaliers qui sont installés sur
10 hectares ils sont céréaliers
boulanger et oui céréaliers boulanger ça
veut dire qu'ils produisent sur 10
hectares ils font vivre une famille sur
dix hectares
ils vendent leurs produits et ils vivent
très bien et bien la console
le principe du contrôle des structures
n'est pas de favoriser la concentration
sur les exploitations préexistantes
mais de permettre à de telles petites
structures de se développer
et c'est l'exemple que je vous donne
correspond effectivement à des
structures périurbaines et aujourd'hui
les gens qui vivent en ville cherchent
des produits venant de cette agriculture
périurbaine
je maintiens donc bien entendu mon
amendement bien mais je vais le mettre
aux voix mais se mêlèrent maintient son
amendement 616 qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté et maintenant
le 462 monsieur mer seront avides
sagesse du gouvernement monsieur le
rapporteur
oui c'est vrai que vous aviez consulter
le ministre et vous avez reçu sa sagesse
j'ai reçu la sagesse grande grande
sagesse des ministres et compte tenu des
éléments qui l'a porté à ce débat je
suis favorable à l'amendement de
monsieur merceron bien
alors monsieur merceron jeu mais où va
votre amendement ceux qui sont pour
veulent bien levé la main unanimité
j'appelle deux amendements qui vont
faire l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 168 rectifié de monsieur botrel puis
le 450 559 colle à ce moment et dans la
même philosophie que le précédent que je
viens de vous lire parmi les
assouplissement du contrôle des
structures intervenue en 2005 et 2006 on
note que désormais les modifications du
nombre d'associés exploitants au co
exploitants ne sont plus soumises à
autorisation la diminution du nombre
d'associés qui pourtant permet de
concentrer plus ha entre les mains de
moins d'agriculteurs n'est plus
considéré comme un agrandissement
le résultat est sans équivoque sans
obligation de dossiers soumis à
autorisation
il n'y a pas de publicité pendant trois
mois des changements en cours qui
permettaient auparavant aux demandes
concurrentes de se manifester ou même
aux demandes de remplacement des
associés qui se sont retirés
nous retombons que dans la problématique
de l'installation de jeunes agriculteurs
dans le cadre sociétaires qui sont
confrontés à de nombreux obstacles
conséquence aussi de cet assouplissement
la cdoa n'est plus consultés ce qui
oblige le gouvernement nous proposer
dans ce projet de loi une nouvelle
commission départementale du contrôle du
foncier agricole
alors qu'il suffirait de réactiver les
contrôles passés d'autres amendements
visent donc à ce que toute diminution du
nombre total d associer exploitant des
co exploitants déco divisèrent des co
indivisaires pardon au sein d'une
exploitation soit assimilée à un
agrandissement
elle entraîne pour celui ou ceux qui
poursuivent la mise en valeur de
l'exploitation l'obligation de
solliciter une autorisation préalable
pour continuer d'exploiter dès lors que
l'exploitation en cause a une superficie
supérieure au seuil fixé au premier
alinéa du premier du article l 331 2 du
code rural et de la pêche maritime dans
ce cas l'autorisation peut être accordée
à titre provisoire pour une durée qui ne
seraient excédés deux ans afin de
permettre le cas échéant de remettre
leur exploitation en conformité avec les
prescriptions du schéma directeur
départemental des structures ces
présidents que l'un présentait le vôtre
s'il vous plaît monsieur le président
monsieur mise mes chers collègues
cet amendement 559 a été très bien
défendue par notre collègue du groupe
socialiste il allait il est dans la même
philosophie est confirmée simplement que
la diminution du nombre d'associés
exploitant des co exploitants ou cody au
sein d'une entreprise agricole abouti en
fait un agrandissement mais cet
amendement 10 vise donc à rétablir
l'équité dans le contrôle de la taille
des structures à la soumettant à une
autorisation préalable vous l'aurez
compris partageons l'avis du groupe
socialiste sur ce fondement que je vous
demande de voter bien monsieur le
rapporteur
je répondrai donc au président colin et
aux sirènes yannick botrel que la
diminution du nombre d'associés
exploitants conduit mécaniquement comme
s'était dit augmenter la surface par
associer soumettre la diminution du
nombre d'associés aux contres les
structures me paraît très difficile
dans la pratique des choses en effet
cette diminution peut résulter de
plusieurs et plusieurs causes pas
forcément volontaires la maladie le
décès mais aussi les difficultés
économiques à notre écurie de le
soumettre à autorisation préalable
la bourse
une activité agricole existant c'est
donc un avis favorable monsieur le
président ma langue a fourché pour le
138 est de 559 monsieur le ministre
votre avis même avis défavorable pour
les mêmes raisons que précédemment tout
ce qui peut alourdir la gestion de la
culture en france nous paraît pas aller
dans le bon sens bien et ils
maintenaient sont-ils maintenu les deux
amendements
oui je l'aimé aux voix un parent oui le
168 rectifié de monsieur botrel qu'ils
adoptent avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté et je suppose 559 rectifié
monsieur colin même vote
il n'est pas à deux explications de vote
dans madame hervio vous avez
l'explication louis très bref monsieur
le président je regrette
il n'est pas dans notre volonté
d'alourdir mais ce que je dénonçais tout
à l'heure dans une façon déguisée de
transférer son exploitation un
agrandissement lorsque un exploitant qui
arrive est quasiment l'âge de la
retraite décidé de
ne pas louer ou de ne pas céder son
exposition à untel ou untel est donc
rentré dans un gaec est bien ce que l'on
vient de refuser c'était le deuxième
volet c'était la seule façon de
contrecarrer ces dérives
je le regrette profondément bien alors
je le mets aux voix la ville se
montraient leurs explications de vote
juste une prise de parole pour prolonger
ce que ma collègue vient de dire mais il
est clair aujourd'hui que il y à une
utilisation des modes sociétaire de
l'agriculture qui est détourné parce que
on peut désormais rentrer dans un gars
est grand temps une structure sociétaire
avoir la possibilité de le faire et on
sait très bien que c'est un subterfuge
et que très rapidement bien l'un des
associés cède sa place on échappe au
contrôle des structures et on renforce
les moyens de production d'un
agriculteur au détriment du contrôle qui
s'est effectuée auparavant
donc moi je veux bien que je suis pas
non plus un forcené de l'alourdissement
des contrôles mais il ya un moment où il
faut savoir ce qu'on veut et si on veut
installer des jeunes si c'est la
finalité de la police des plats
politique que l'on conduit et bien il
faut aussi savoir se donner les moyens
pour le faire bien je pense que
maintenant on peut voter ceux qui sont
pour veulent bien levé la main avec
contraire il n'est pas adopté j'appelle
438 rectifié de madame hervio elle a la
parole oui monsieur le président merci
je crois que pour ne pas alourdir et
continuer les débats cet amendement 436
dans son fond même si les parisiens tout
à fait de la même façon rejoint les
amendements défendus par mes c'est colin
et monsieur botrel tout à l'heure donc
je proposerai le retrait bien entendu
puisque je sais qui va subir le même
sort que les autres mais je
réitère mes avertissements et
ne pas alourdir bien entendu toutes les
contrôles c'est notre souhait à tous
mais évitez de laisser faire tout les
les chemins de traverse pour aller vers
l'agrandissement c'est tout à fait autre
chose
merci monsieur versement vous présenter
le 459 oui il est dans le droit fil de
ce qui vient d'être indiqué donc
l'objectif du présent amendement vise
donc à rétablir l'équité entre le
contrôle de la taille des structures en
soumettant à autorisation les
arrondissements liée à la diminution du
nombre d'associés exploitants au sein
d'une exploitation agricole à consulter
le rapporteur oui merci monsieur
président l'amendement de madame hervio
revient sur une simplification du
contrôle structure qui adopté dans le
cadre de la dernière loi d'orientation
école c'était nous étions tous là
c'était 1-1 donc en décembre 2005
il s'agit t il s'agissait à l'époque
d'éviter de faire appel à ces des world
en d4 pose peu de difficultés il paraît
de plus en plus difficile d'empêcher un
associé à partie deux parties en
exploitation donc je suis pas favorable
à cet amendement
mais il est sûr à celui de 459 de
monsieur merceron mais j'en rajoutais à
titre personnel que les cdo à il faut
qu'elles fonctionnent aussi et la
difficulté c'est que la loi est faite
pour toute la france
mais après il appartient à chaque cdoa
de mettre en place un certain nombre de
prérogatives qu'elle sort elle même à
même de disposer mais je crois que
c'était la volonté des personnes qui
siègent cdoa de régler tel était le
problème
moi je fais confiance aux cdo à pour les
traiter et essayer de les régler
voilà votre avis sur ces deux
amendements défavorables comme la
commission alors je mets aux voileux 436
rectifié de madame hervio qui le vote
ceux qui sont favorables à madame airs
du récent amendement veulent bien levé
la main indique contraire il n'est pas
adoptée et monsieur
merceron vous le maintenez vous le
retirez il est retiré
bien que vous remercie maintenance nous
appelons le 167 rectifié de monsieur
votre aile et la parole oui monsieur le
président compte tenu du sort que notre
assemblée a fait aux deux amendements
précédent et ne pensons pas qu'elle va
se déjuger par un nouveau vote je le
retire
merci monsieur merceron aussi le 468
vous le retirez vous le maintenez retiré
bien je vous remercie
alors après l'article 12 b nous avons un
amendement de notre collègue monsieur le
cam 296 puis sur le président semi chers
collègues brièvement l'accès à la terre
est un des grands enjeux de la pérennité
de l'activité agricole
un des axes majeurs pour lutter contre
l'artificialisation des terres et le
contrôle des structures
nous pensons donc il est nécessaire
d'élargir le champ d'application de ce
contrôle
dans cet objectif nous proposons de
modifier le régime de l'infraction à la
législation sur le contrôle des
structures en effet en l'état actuel du
droit lorsqu'elle constate qu'un fonds
est exploité contrairement à la
législation en vigueur
l'autorité administrative mais l'auteur
en demeure de régulariser sa situation
dans un délai qu'elle détermine et qui
ne saurait être inférieure à un mois
or ce délai parfois anormalement long
nous proposons que ce délai soit au
maximum porté à trois mois c'est
l'essence de notre amendement
je vous remercie quel est l'avis du
rapporteur
moi je souhaiterais avoir l'avis de
monsieur le ministre parce que c'est une
possibilité qui est offerte
j'aurais connaître l'avis de monsieur
ministre est pas normand monsieur mains
porter mais un la parole est aux
ministres j'apprécie beaucoup les
normands monsieur le président
il nous semble je vois bien je vois bien
le sens de l'amendement déposé par
gérard le cam
j'ai peur là encore que imposé de durées
différentes risque encore de compliquer
la procédure je sais bien que la tension
sont bonnes qu'il s'agit de répondre à
des situations qui peuvent être
différentes
mais en imposant de dire est différente
le remède reese est pire que le mal
c'est qu'on va encore alourdir la
procédure encore compliqué la procédure
donc pour ces raisons là c'est un avis
défavorable
maintenant je le mets aux voix qui est
favorable à leur demande monsieur le
calme est ce qu'il ya des avis contraire
il n'est pas adoptée après l'article 12
bis toujours nous avons trois
amendements qui vont faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune indre sur colin et de
monsieur le cas monsieur koné faisait la
parole 548 rectifié monsieur klein sur
le président soumise mais chers
collègues le critère d'affiliation
régime de protection sociale à des non
salariés des professions agricoles est
aujourd'hui celui de la superficie de
l'exploitation ce critère semble de
moins en moins adaptées aux évolutions
de l'aviculture
il ne prend pas en compte les projets
intégrant une valorisation une
transformation ou une commercialisation
de la production sur à la ferme il ne
permet pas d'hésitation progressive avec
une acquisition sur plusieurs mois
il diffère fortement d'un département à
l'autre
il ne prend pas en compte les plus
réactifs et par ailleurs la pression
foncière s'étant fortement accentuée au
cours des dernières années
l'obligation d'accès à une surface
minimum de terre et très discriminante
pour les candidats à l'installation
en fait la mise en place du statut de
l'auto entrepreneur dans les régions
dans les régimes sociaux autres
qu'agricoles interroge légitimement le
comprend dans les agriculteurs cet
amendement propose donc de conditionner
l'accès au statut de chef d'exploitation
ou d'entreprise agricole à une
déclaration d'heures de travail fixé par
décret tenant compte du temps de travail
nécessaire à la conduite de cette
exploitation ou entreprises cette
possibilité existe déjà mais dépend de
l'appréciation des conseils
d'administration des caisses de
mutualité sociale agricole
on pourrait aussi retenir un critère
basée sur le chiffre d'affaires nous
sommes conscients que les conséquences
d'un tel changement interne droits
sociaux sont lourds et mérite un débat
approfondi sans doute il s'agit surtout
pas cet amendement de lancer la
réflexion sur ce sujet mais aussi
d'interroger le gouvernement sur ses
intentions je remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le calme si vous voulez
présente maintenant excusez moi faisons
tv2 même esprit je défendrai les
amendements de 180 et 282 ensemble non
la loi aurait dû être le moment de
s'attaquer au problème de l'accès au
métier au statut d'exploitant l'accès au
métier de paysan et conditionner l'accès
au statut social de chef d'exploitation
celui ci confère une reconnaissance de
l'activité agricole de la personne et
donne donc accès aux droits spécifiques
des paysans aides agricoles priorité
d'accès au foncier permis de construire
sur des terres agricoles droits sociaux
droit de vote aux élections
professionnelles
le problème c'est que l'accès au statut
est lui-même conditionné la direction
d'une ferme dont la portance doit être
au minimum d'une demi surface minimum
d'installation
cette référence pose de nouveaux
problèmes déjà exposé elle ne prend pas
en compte les projets intégrant une
valorisation une transformation une
commercialisation de la production de la
ferme la demie s est mis et ses écrits
et ses équivalents ce sont en effet
basés sur des modèles productivistes
classique elle mais elle ne permet pas
l'installation progressive avec une
acquisition sur plusieurs mois 2,2 sur
la production nécessaire de plus la
pression foncière s'est fortement
accentuée au cours des dernières années
rendant obligatoire à une semie de
terres agricoles très discriminante et
coûteuse pour les candidats à
l'installation
elle diffère fortement d'un département
à l'autre et les équivalences n'existe
pas de la même façon
enfin ce critère ne prend aucunement en
considération la situation des plus
réactifs
nous proposons donc de conditionner le
statut non plus par une taille mini
d'exploitation mais par une déclaration
d'heures de travail comme cela existe
déjà pour certaines activités
nous dénonçons par ailleurs le statut de
cotisants solidaires qui n'ouvre aucun
droit professionnel à des paysans en
activité ainsi les cotisants solidaires
non retraités avec une activité agricole
sont environ cent mille en france les
pouvoirs publics ont reconnu
implicitement la réalité de leurs
activités en leur ouvrant en 2008 des
droits pour les accidents du travail les
maladies professionnelles et
prochainement pour la formation
professionnelle
il est désormais nécessaire que le
gouvernement aille plus loin en ouvrant
l'accès au statut de chef d'exploitation
à ses cotisants solidaires
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
votre avis sur les trois pays monsieur
le président c'est le même avis madame
la barre et eu la gentillesse de
défendre le 281 282 pour le faire une
je la remercie au nom de tous
cet amendement donc qui a été déposée
par le président colin 258 vise à faire
entrer de la régime la protection
sociale agricole des personnes qui ne
correspondent pas tout à fait la
définition des spots à l'école conjoint
est en activité extérieure à
l'exploitation et qui travaille
seulement une partie du temps sur
l'exploitation
je rappelle que nous avons eu déjà ce
débat et qui semble que le régime à
equal ii reste est réservé à ceux qui se
consacrent à faire fonctionner les
exploitations viables
c'est à dire ayant le talent minimale
c'était l'avis défavorable pour les
trois monsieur prise à monsieur le
ministre votre avis sur ces trois avis
défavorable également moi je précise
simplement que le critère qui existe
actuellement deux demi et s'est mis nous
paraît adaptée à la réalité l'activité
agricole car il prend en compte la
rentabilité des productions ainsi que le
mode de production exercé comme cela est
indiqué tout à l'heure c'est équivalence
s est mis et défini pour chaque nature
de culture par département avec des
spécificités par département donc nous
estimons que cela tient déjà compte de
la réalité de la vie agricole sur chaque
département merci alors monsieur colin
maintenez vous votre amendement
je le mets aux voix le 548 rectifié
quels sont ceux qui s'en fout
avis contraire il n'est pas adoptée
280,1 maintenue et le 282 également donc
jeu mais on voit d'abord de 280 qui est
pour avis contraire pas adopter et je
suppose même veine sur le suivant pas
d'objection n'ont pas adopté
j'appelle maintenant leur l'allemand 26
rectifié quater d'émotion le rosé oui
merci aux surprises ont subsisté chaque
collègue les jeunes chefs d'exploitation
d'entreprises agricoles bénéficient
pendant les cinq années civil suivant la
réinstallation une exonération partielle
des cotisations techniques
complémentaires d'assurance maladie
invalidité maternité de prestations
familiales et d'assurance vieillesse
agricoles dont ils sont redevables pour
eux mêmes et au titre de leur
exploitation entreprises une dérogation
a été accordée aux jeunes chefs
d'exploitation ou d'entreprise agricole
au type de l'année 2009
on sait le contexte dans lequel se situe
l'agriculture et les difficultés de
l'ensemble des agriculteurs mais
particulièrement des jeunes
donc il est proposé de reconduire
monsieur ministre cette mesure président
colin 555 rectifié s'il vous plaît oui
collex amendement déjà défendue par
contre collègue hervé me semble-t-il
effectivement les jeunes chefs
d'exploitation d'entreprises bénéficient
ça vient d'être dit pendant cinq ans les
cinq année civile suivant l'arrestation
de l'exonération partielle des
cotisations technique et complet un
terme à la diabolique et maternité
prestations familiales choisi agricole
et c'est vrai que bien souvent en termes
ces cinq angles les nouveaux installés
sont loin d'avoir atteint le régime de
croisière et d'être bien installés alors
de l'eau investissons en plaisantant sur
eux leur trésorier faible souvent venus
d'ailleurs et donc qu'il est proposé
comme ça a été dit déjà par cet
amendement de prolonger d'une année
supplémentaire
cette exonération monsieur leurs portes
notre avis oui monsieur le président on
pourrait étendre après six ans et en 8
ans 9 ans 10 ans 20 ans 50 ans jusqu'à
arriver c'est pas possible
donc c'est un avis défavorable bien
monsieur le ministre les défavorables
aussi monsieur le président je tiens
quand même à rappeler que l'exonération
actuelle de 5 ans dégressive et de 65 %
la première année 55 35 25 et 15
ensuite les années suivantes donc bien
entendu nous sommes tout à fait décidée
à soutenir l'installation et les jeunes
agriculteurs je pense qu'on nous
montrera dans la suite du débat mais on
ne peut pas multiplier les exonérations
celle ci je le dis au passage coûterait
4 millions d'euros par an aux finances
publiques
monsieur vais me retirer vous bien et
président colin vous le retirez
également je vous en remercie les
ministres et rapporteur nouveau à nyon
convaincu alors j'appelle le 48 rectifié
terre de ce printemps il tombe personne
ne le défend il est tombé ensuite le 115
ça me semble pareil il tombe il ya le
je ne vois pas de collègues qui
souhaitent le défendre et ensuite il y a
un un col 1 551 rectifier
un joli colin alors le fondement de la
protection sociale est que chacun cotise
selon ses moyens bénéficier des
prestations selon ses besoins
or les exploitants doivent s'acquitter
quelles que soient leurs revenus d'une
cotisation minimale basé sur une
assiette égale à 8 cents ce mic soit un
montant de 755 euros pour 2009 pour
avoir droit à une couverture maladie
les exploitants les plus en difficulté
paie donc proportionnellement plus que
les autres et sur des sommes qui n'ont
pas perçu cette assiette minimum a eu sa
raison d'être mais elle n'est plus
justifiée aujourd'hui du fait de
l'existence à sa mue cet amendement vise
donc de façon logique supprimés je vous
remercie
alors monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
le président a joué au répondant au
président collen que les exploitants
cotisants aimé ça en fonction de leurs
revenus
comme chacun sait une assiette est
minimale existe à un niveau très bas
700 euros aux parents elle ouvre des
droits sociaux qui ne sommes pas
différents de ceux dont bénéficient les
agriculteurs que dix ans plus j'ajoute
que l'assiette est minimale existe aussi
dans le régime des indépendants
les messins dispose des solutions
d'étalement des cotisations entre la
difficulté temporaire ce qui se fait
régulièrement la suppression de
l'assiette minimale et donc pas
souhaitable sans même entrer dans les
considérations budgétaires
c'est un avis défavorable le ministre
vis défavorable sur le col 1 48 très
cliché terre parce que il est évident
qu'on ne peut pas avoir deux régimes de
protection sociale sans une assiette
minimum
bien il est retiré mathieu blin bien je
vous remercie
alors le 440 rectifié jean guillaume
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet amant
noah on va dans le sens de ce qui a été
évoqué précédemment
étant donné le niveau élevé de
l'assiette minimum de cotisation pour la
retraite complémentaire obligatoire des
chefs d'exploitations agricoles
ce sont ni plus ni moins que 70% d'entre
eux qui sur cotisent et cet amendement
vise à aborder la surcotisation dans le
contexte de crise sans précédent
qu'affronte le monde paysan est alors
que le revenu moyen agricole n'a cessé
de chuter ces dernières années pour être
quasiment à -50%
il n'est pas tolérable de laisser
surcotiser dans de telles proportions
ceux qui ne parviennent déjà plus à
vivre des fruits de leur travail
nous nous devions de corriger cette
injustice c'est pourquoi avec cet
amendement
nous vous proposons de diviser par trois
le niveau de l'assiette minimum de l'air
seo en l'alignant celui de l'assurance
vieillesse agricoles ce qui serait une
mesure de justice sociale
bien sûr l'état devrait s'engager à ce
que le nombre minimum de poids qui reste
stable à 100 points par an mais
n'entrons pas dans la technique
monsieur le ministre dans cette lm ap
jeu nous comprenons pourquoi pas un seul
des articles n'évoque la retraite
agricole
le grand débat qui est lancé au niveau
national sur les retraites permettra
vraisemblement d'ivoire d'ivoire
plus clair mais pour autant dans cette
loi de modernisation agricole
on peut constater que le niveau de
cotisation pose problème que les
retraités agricoles aujourd'hui en
d'énormes difficultés et aussi avec des
retraites vraiment minime pour ne pas
dire insignifiante que les maigres
pensions ne sont pas responsables de la
disparition des exploitations agricoles
et la consommation du foncier rigole
aujourd'hui pour partir en retraite bien
souvent eh bien on va essayer on va
insister pour demander au maire vous
faire passer le les terres agricoles en
terre à construction constructibles pour
pouvoir avoir un revenu et on entre dans
la déprise agricole mais c'est un autre
c'est un autre sujet alors dans ce texte
de modernisation il nous semble que la
question des retraites aurait pu si ce
n'est être intégré au moins être évoquée
et je veux rappeler ici mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'aborder cela dans le grand
débat qui va s'ouvrir à la rentrée que
lorsqu'on parle de réforme des retraites
80 % des agriculteurs se prononce pour
le maintien du départ à 60 ans ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils arrêtent de
travailler à 60 ans travaille jusqu'à
110 75 peut-être mais ils sont
favorables à ce que l'âge légal de la
retraite soit bien 60 ans parce que
lorsqu'on parle de pénibilité et de
travaux difficiles
je dois dire que pour bon nombre
d'agriculteurs ils savent ce que ce que
cela veut dire
donc en attendant cette fameuse réforme
des retraites les chefs d'exploitations
agricoles nous semble-t-il ne peuvent
continuer à surcotiser ainsi et nous
vous invitons donc à adopter notre
amendement
monsieur le reporter votre ami oui merci
monsieur président ni dit guillaume a
parlé d'un grand débat si je reprends
son terme sur les retraites qui aura
lieu bien sûr dans l'année 2010 est donc
l'amendement concernant l'assiette
minimale de retraite comme l'inter fera
sans doute l'objet de legrand
discussions dans un grand débat tel que
le propose et dit guillaume est pour
aujourd'hui je donne un avis défavorable
sur le moment sur le moment monsieur le
ministre
avis défavorable également monsieur le
président qu'il soit bien clair que ce
n'est pas sur le fond et sur la question
des retraites agricoles qui est une
vraie question
mais nous avons été reçus et que les
organisations syndicales représentatives
de continueront à l'être par eric woerth
sur cette question là il ya
effectivement sur les années de
référence sur l'accès au montant minimal
de retrait sur lesquels il ya des points
de blocage des vrais sujets et nous
souhaitons que cela soit traitée dans le
cadre de la réforme des retraites bien
est il maintenu monsieur vous avez la
parole pas l'explication doit être très
dépendants oui très très vite nous
allons maintenir par principe pour une
raison très sympa par rapport à ce qui
est dit parce que je que je j'entends en
cela mais tout simplement parce que la
troisième en deux noms qui avaient été
présentées sur ce sujet et et trois
amendements qui ont été pris par le cou
pleurer de l'article de l'article 40
dont on pense qu'il est parfois à
géométrie plus que variable mais c'est
comme cela
donc voila nous nous allons maintenir
cet amendement en disant bien quand même
et on voulait nous voulions dans cette
loi de modernisation agricole
on en voit on pas du revenu des
agriculteurs je pense qu'il ne faut pas
oublier les revenus des retraités
agricoles qui bien souvent continue à
aider leurs enfants continuent à mener
le tracteur continue à aller labourer et
c est ça être bien aussi à faire
fonctionner l'affectionné d'exploitation
donc voilà j'ai entendu monsieur le
ministre il se rapportera vous parler de
la forme le président du moment et non
pas sur le fond je pense que le fonds
des retraites agricoles et je peux vous
dire qu'un jeu à ce que touche mon père
comme retraites agricoles
je me dis que c'est vraiment une honte
mais enfin c'est comme cela et je nous
le maintenons bien je vous remercie
alors je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement qui ceux qui sont favorables
veulent bien levé la main et ce qui est
des avis contraire c'est surtout à cause
de taille mais il n'est pas adopté
le gouvernement un amendement 653 je
vais demander au ministre de le
présenter monsieur le ministre c'est à
vous en direct
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui est important à nos yeux
qui est demandé par beaucoup
d'organisations syndicales et qui est en
faveur de la protection sociale des
jeunes pendant la phase de pré
installation
vous savez que les jeunes qui veulent
s'installer lorsqu'ils sont nés à partir
de 1971 qui nos pattes le cas de
beaucoup d'entre nous ici
malheureusement sauf ceux qui
participent aux débats du haut des
galeries peuvent bénéficier d'un plan de
professionnalisation personnalisé
or pour toutes sortes de raisons les
régimes sociaux sont différents pour les
uns et pour les autres cet amendement
c'est un amendement de simplification et
d'unification des régimes
nous souhaitons que la protection
sociale du futur installé pendant les
pubs de formation pendant les périodes
de stage effectué au cours du délai de
trois ans de réalisation du plan de
professionnalisation soit affilié au
même régime
alors qu'aujourd'hui sont affiliés
pendant six mois au régime agricole
pendant six mois ensuite au régime
général ce qui induit des complexités
administratives et également des pertes
de revenu par la suite sera porteur
j'aimerais connaître votre sentiment
oui cet amendement répond à une demande
que j'avais moi même et aussi il est
membre de la commission le président et
maureen en particulier exprimé dans le
cadre d'une discussion avec le ministère
il est en effet essentiel que les
porteurs de projets d'installations
bénéficient d'une couverture sociale
adaptée la commission ne pourrait pas
elle-même le proposer puisque cette
couverture sociale créé une charge pour
la collectivité
je salue l'initiative prise par le
gouvernement mais surtout par le
ministre bruno le maire qui répond
pleinement à la volonté exprimée par là
notre commission économique d'introduire
un volet sur l'installation dans la loi
d'orientation de l'agriculture
vous êtes favorable bien c'est une
surprise ce moment
monsieur revêt un monsieur le président
simplement pour remercier ministre parce
que je crois que c'est une très bonne
disposition attendu par les jeunes parce
qu'il ya une situation très complexe
bon bien entendu nous le voterons
presque à demain si c'était possible
l'assistance et la parole oui quelques
mon explication de vote
tout d'abord pour me féliciter sur un
plan plus général que suite aux travaux
noté de la commission ya eu introduction
d'un titre sur l'installation dans ce
projet de loi de modernisation agricole
je crois que c'était très important
lorsqu'on parle de modernisation en
aviculture il est évident que ça passe
aussi par que par ça mais ça passe aussi
par les moyens de favoriser
l'installation de jeunes également
d'ailleurs de moins jeunes parce qu'il y
à des candidats qui ne sont pas
forcément aucune peuvent pas être
forcément qualifié de jeune
en ce qui concerne l'amendement proposé
par le gouvernement je vais vous faire
gagner du temps mes chers collègues tout
simplement parce que je pense que nous
soutiendrons cet amendement du
gouvernement dans la mesure où il répond
à une préoccupation que j'ai moi même
exprimé dans un amendement 408 qui
allait suivre qui demandait comme quoi
parfois un rapport ou un bilan peut
rejoindre une préoccupation partagée
mais va plus loin que ce que je
proposais c'est-à-dire pour permettre
une il faut uniformiser à sion une
harmonisation des régimes sociaux
pendant les périodes installations
notamment par là pendant la période de
de préparation du plan de
professionnalisation pour les candidats
à l'installation
donc je me réjouis que cet amendement
puisse être validé
conformément à ce que souhaitait
notamment les jeunes agriculteurs bien
évidemment et qui correspond aussi au
souhait que nous souhaitions exprimer
car il me paraît effectivement
importante pour faciliter ce parcours
qu'on puisse aussi répondre à ces
problématiques sociales que nous avons
exprimé à différentes reprises y compris
sur d'autres questions touchant
l'installation en agriculture est donc
bien entendu pour conclure effectivement
j'annonce d'ores et déjà que je
retirerai du coup
l'examen du la différence du 14 8 je
vous remercie monsieur chasse tom et
vous êtes devenu conseiller technique du
ministre sur le 653 si j'ai bien compris
alors je mets je mets le 653 du
gouvernement au vote
unanimité pas d'abstention adopté et
merci monsieur chastan d'avoir retiré
donc le 408 qui est satisfait
j'en arrive maintenant au 43 rectifié
bis
il tombe j'arrive maintenant alors à
plusieurs amendements qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 418
27 qu'inquiets seraient qualifiés et le
7 556 et 344 rectifié bis monsieur sur
qui le défend madame nique ou madame
nicole nico connexion j'étais un peu oui
ça fait plusieurs fois
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je serai très
rapide donc cet amendement vise à
permettre aux agriculteurs de compter
dans leurs actifs mobiles à l'actif de
leur bilan la maison d'habitation comme
un bien professionnel indissociable du
corps de ferme dans la mesure où les
jeunes agriculteurs récemment installé
rencontrent des difficultés pour trouver
un logement et dans certains cas la
maison d'habitation peut être plus et
nour plus onéreuse que l'exploitation
agricole elle même je vous remercie
monsieur charles revêt et vous avez dû
beaucoup pensé à votre annonce qui a été
rectifiée cinq fois et oui oui oui il
fait vrai et vous avez raison monsieur
le président c'était après des
discussions et des rencontres proposent
avec les jeunes que je les déposer mais
je me suis interrogé parce que je me
suis souvenu que j'avais était jeune il
ya déjà quelques années et que j'avais
eu le même problème est que je m'étais
interrogé si je devais inclure
l'amortissement de la maison
d'habitation dans l'outil d'exploitation
pas et je ne l'avais exclu pour des
raisons techniques de des queues de
reprise potentielle
donc je ne sais pas où on en est mais
c'était monsieur mais nice pour que vous
nous donniez cette information à
destination des ja
qui pourront choisir après le meilleur
choix qu'ils auront à faire pour leur
exploitation plus ou moins bien l'amorti
si je comprends bien non rien bon
monsieur colle à ce plaisir monsieur
mise c'est moi qui dit mes chers
collègues cet amendement s'inscrit dans
le même esprit l effet les jeunes est
allé rencontrer difficultés pour trouver
un logement a été dit et répété un
certain cas d'ailleurs la maison
d'habitation peut-être plus onéreuse que
l'exploitation agricole elle-même et
afin d'aider les jeunes à trouver un
heureusement beau mais aussi pour lutter
contre le mitage du foncier agricole il
faut offrir la possibilité aux nouveaux
extraits d'amortir la maison
d'habitation
lorsque ces derniers ont choisi de
l'inscrire à l'actif de leurs voeux
bilan donc la maison d'habitation
deviendrait ainsi un bien professionnel
indissociable du corps de ferme voilà
l'esprit de cette maman je vous ai bien
compris le père tombe trois ans alors
monsieur le rapporteur
vous me donnez merci sur les trois
amendements merci monsieur le président
comme ils sont tous pareils tous les
trois on va donner le même avis mais je
rappelle que l'article 38 16 pièces des
annexes de 3 du cgi prévoit déjà que la
maison d'habitation de l'exploitant
agricole peut être inscrite à l'actif du
bilan d'exploitation condition de faire
partie physiquement d'exploitation ne
pas présenter le caractère des maisons
de maître est donc cet amendement et
descentes satisfait par le droit
existant donc je demande le retrait en
trois collègues par rapport donc à la
satisfaction qu'ils ont que déjà le
problème est réglé par anticipation
depuis longtemps est ce que nos
ministres confiant parce que le premier
amendement est un peu différent des deux
autres enjeux confiant la question tout
à fait pertinentes posées par mon ami
normand charles revêt c'est de savoir si
on peut rendre la maison d'habitation
d'une exploitation rurale amortissable
et la réponse est oui
donc la réponse à votre amendement 27
rectifié qu'inquiets ce c'est l'article
38 sexe decies comme quoi le code
général des impôts corrige encore
ces textes que charles revêt ses
amendements et cet article prévoit
explicitement que la maison d'habitation
du propriétaire exploitant peut faire
partie de l'amortissement sous réserve
effectivement qu'elle fasse
effectivement partie de l'exploitation
en gros si vous avez une exploitation
auprès de fécamp et que vous avez une
maison qui se trouve à nice évidemment
la maison à nice n'est pas amortissable
en revanche si vous avez une
exploitation laitière dans le pays de
caux ce qui peut arriver cher charles
revêt et que votre maison d'habitation
fait partie de cette exploitation
laitière elle est amortissable
voilà alors monsieur revêt ce qu il yad
autres parce que je voulais savoir ce
qu'ils qui avait défendu le premier de
ces monsieur chasse non c'est madame
banon
vous souhaitez oui je sais pas cher pas
utiliser le prénom vous le retirer il
est satisfait monsieur relevé je
remercie monsieur le ministre c'est ce
qui justifie à votre interrogation ce
président est mais je crois qu'il faut
bien informées des jeunes que ce qui
peut apparaître comme une facilité peut
se retourner à terme contre eux et bien
entendu en pays de caux c'est toujours
dans l'app le clos masure mais mais mais
myers a peut être autrement mais je
crois qu'il faut c'est une très bonne
disposition c'est prévu dans les textes
mais je crois qu'il faut bien informer
les jeunes que dès lors qu'ils mortis
leurs biens ne leur appartient plus tout
à fait parce qu'à terme il peut y avoir
remises en cause et récupération par le
fisc
dès lors qu'il aura été amortis je crois
qu'il faut il faut regarder ça de très
près pour avant qu'il s'entêtait ou
fassent leur choix et après c'est
l'heureux à leur disposition retirer
aussi bien je vous remercie et
maintenant quatre nouveaux avant
c'est monsieur le cadre le 314 monsieur
vous avez la parole car d'une plage
isolée s'il ya un morceau qui tombait
non
je suis désolé j'ai perdu un morceau bon
oui en fait c'est un amendement après
aux retraites
effectivement nous n'allons pas réglé
cette question dans ce texte mais nous
voulions tout de même attiré l'attention
du gouvernement sur la situation des
retraites agricoles dans la mesure où le
président de la république avait annoncé
un filet de sécurité
et parmi ces les annonces faites à
l'époque de des mesures en ce qui
concerne la revalorisation des petites
retraites agricoles était déjà amorcée
depuis janvier 2007
je vise ici la suppression des pénalités
pour années manquantes et l'abaissement
du nombre d'années de carrière non
salariés agricoles pour y accéder en
revanche le silence du gouvernement est
assourdissant ce qui concerne à un
niveau satisfaisant de revalorisation
des retraites
en effet le résultat obtenu n'est
absolument pas à la hauteur du discours
tenu est des attentes du monde agricole
sur plus de 1,7 million de retraités non
salariés agricoles seuls 190000 des plus
petites retraites ont bénéficié d'une
revalorisation soit 11 % de l'ensemble
des retraités 80% des valorisations
étaient d'un montant inférieur à 50
euros
40% des organisations ont été d'un
montant inférieur à 10 euros par mois
pourtant les retraités non salariés de
l'agriculture ont les plus bas niveaux
de retraite actuellement en france 40%
des monopensionnés qui n'ont donc pas
d'autre retraite perçoivent moins de 500
euros par mois et 90% n'atteignent pas
le seuil du seuil de pauvreté qui est de
817 euros par mois par cet amendement
donc nous demandons un engagement sur un
point qui nous paraît essentiel
une retraite minimum à 85% du smic pour
tous les non salariés agricoles
présentant une carrière complète comme
cela existe déjà depuis 2003 pour les
salariés c'est le sens de cet amendement
parfait qui déforme pour le groupe
madame renée
je pense que je serai très brève puisque
didier guillaume a très bien défendu la
cause des retraites tout à l'heure je
rajouterais tout simplement le fait que
nous sommes tous d'accord ici pour
reconnaître qu'il n'est pas acceptable
qu'un exploitant et on travaillait à
temps complet touchent moins de 7 2 897
euros à la retraite
donc c'est un montant plancher qui est
temps qu'il est encore trop bas selon
nous et qu'il constituerait un progrès
pour certains agriculteurs donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'appelle à voter
pour cet amendement je vous remercie
madame monsieur le président que l'un
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais être un peu redondant
mais c'est un sujet qui nous préoccupe
et qui est un sujet dramatique que nous
vivons très mal sur le terrain la
profession agricole attendaient
d'ailleurs un volet social dans ce texte
notamment sur se brûler d'autres ce
dossier brûlant des retraites mais aussi
celui des pré retraites il s'agit d'un
sujet majeur qui mérite à l'évidence
d'être traité trois agriculteurs
touchent encore aujourd'hui une retraite
de l'ordre de 500 euros alors que le
minimum vieillesse s'élève faut-il le
rappeler à 700 euros et devrait
augmenter si l'on en croit les
engagements du président de la
république de 25% d'ici 2012
ce n'est donc pas acceptant de notre
groupe avait déposé plusieurs
amendements pour permettre à tous ces
hommes et ces femmes qui travaillent dur
de quitter le métier dans des conditions
dignes acceptable
l'un d'eux visé notamment garantir le
versement d'une retraite comme égal
euros minimum vieillesse
ces amendements ont malheureusement été
victime du terrible article 40
il nous reste celui ci qui nous permet
au moins de vous interpeller monsieur le
ministre la loi 2003 775 du 21 août 2003
portant réforme des retraites a inscrit
pour les salariés l'objectif d'une
pension de retraite au moins égal à 80
100 % du smic net
dans un souci d'équité entre les
retraités le même objectif doit être
inscrit pour les non salariés agricoles
près de 90% des monopensionnés
n'atteignez pas cet objectif
faut-il le rappeler en 2007 je crois
monsieur le ministre il faut trouver des
solutions concrètes
pour remédier à cette situation sinon je
les dis tout leur mais je le répète
comme en arriverons nous à susciter des
vocations chez les jeunes lesquels
d'entre eux auraient trouvé dans labeur
de tous les jours pour à peine à rémy un
rémy avec un but sa perspective d'une
retraite misérable je crois qu on est là
face à un problème dramatique qui le
auquel il faut monsieur le ministre
s'attaquer de toute urgence
je vous remercie monsieur muller le 607
rectifié s'il vous plaît il a été
parfaitement défendu par mon collègue
colin donc très bien merci monsieur mes
nerfs alors monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis sur ces quatre amendements
alors c'est vrai que le problème est
dramatique je reprends l'expression de
notre collègue le président collet c'est
vrai qu'il faut améliorer c'est votre
école mais c'est pas là elle et moi je
crois que c'était dit par chacun d'eux
non qu'on va voir ce problème très
important pour l'agriculture
nous le verrons bien sûr comme d
éditique et au moteur lors du grand
débat
je reprends ces termes sur les autres
qui a été ok donc qu'ils sont évoqués
donc deux par le président l'a public
est aussi prêt ministre à l'automne
chantier des retraites
donc c'est la vie fort défavorable pour
les 4 favre a présenté les retraites
mais défavorable pour les amendements
d'accord monsieur le ministre c'est
voudra porter avis défavorable également
monsieur le président pour les mêmes
raisons que j'ai évoquées précédemment
une fois encore nous ne nions pas les
problèmes notamment la question de
l'accès au minimum vieillesse qui est dû
en particulier à la question du recours
sur succession qui fait que beaucoup
d'exploitants agricoles hésitent à
demander l'accès ce milieu vieillesse
mais toutes ces questions là ont été
évoqués directement auprès d'eric woerth
et donc nous les traiterons dans le
cadre de la réforme des retraites bien
le maintenez vous les uns et les autres
compte tenu des explications données par
rapporteur et nos ministres vous le
maintenez bien alors je mets aux voileux
trois balles sont pareils un jeu fait un
seul match où l'un est d'accord bon
explications de vote monsieur muller
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le rapporteur très très
brièvement
je crois qu'il me paraît utile malgré
les la déclaration du ministre
d'inscrire dans une loi de modernisation
que nous souhaitons progresser dans la
matière que l'on travaille sur le sujet
par la suite c'est bien mais aujourd'hui
nous faisons une loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture
je crois qu'il faut indiquer le cap en
matière de retraite
je vous remercie alors je vais mettre
aux voix les amendements 314 4 137 552
et 607 rectifier ce qui sont pour
veulent bien le gamin est ce qu'il ya
des avis contraire compte tenu du timing
oui ne sont pas adoptées nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci d'avoir suivi
cette séance si vous souhaitez la revoir
notre site à dar el publicsenat.fr
à suivre le journal de 18h présenté ce
soir et comme tous les vendredis par
caroline delage bonne soirée à tous